heads up creeps and listeners this  Monday there will not be an episode  dropping as usual but don't worry  because next Monday December 19th will  be back in the studio with the one and  only Danny DeVito there she is my [ __ ]  wife oh man the ham was great  the best bunny  [Music]  Studio this Monday December 12th at 6 PM  Pacific we'll be celebrating the  holidays by porn cocktails playing games  and interacting with all of you so come  party with us from the comfort of your  own home for a good cause because all  proceeds from ticket sales will be  donated to charity just go to moment.co  always sunny to buy your ticket me a  money needing a lot now happy holidays  from your friends at the Always Sunny  podcast I love you guys  [Music]